[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock here in the uk you're very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news this morning
he's calling it a cruel lottery and
today mps will vote on the prime
minister's plans to hike taxes to help
fix the social care crisis we'll ask the
health secretary javid how breaking
promises to the public sits with him we
also ask him about a warning from the
astrazeneca boss that booster jabs may
not be needed for everybody
it was like a new snowfall
this muffled
sound of silence
and for a few seconds
we wondered if we were still alive
remembering 9 11 we speak to the first
fire chief on the scene of the attack at
the world trade center ahead of the 20th
anniversary
in addition keeping it quiet we speak to
the former welsh rugby player gareth
thomas about why many men don't want to
share their health concerns on national
suicide prevention month it's wednesday
the 8th of september
ending the cruel lottery of who can meet
care costs without facing ruin the prime
minister defends his tax hike to fix the
social care crisis as mp is prepared to
vote on it
i'm live in downing street as boris
johnson takes a big political gamble
will mps back his tax hike to support
the nhs and social care
and i'm live off the coast of calais the
home secretary wants you might withhold
funding if french authorities don't do
more to intercept migrants in these
waters
and i'm here in manchester as a new
report reveals that people in the north
of england were more likely to die from
covid and spent longer in lockdown
freeing britney the superstar's father
files a legal petition to end the
conservatorship that controlled her
personal life and finances for the last
13 years
[Music]
the consequences of terror survivors of
the bataclan attack prepared to testify
in france's biggest ever trial where
they're live
although the heat and the sunshine
continues from many today the weather
will turn cooler and more unsettled over
the next few days
[Music]
morning the prime minister has defended
his plans to fix the social care crisis
with a tax hack by saying the government
needs to end the cruel lottery of who or
who will not face financial ruin to meet
their care costs in just a couple of
minutes time we'll be joined by the
health secretary sergey javid also today
ahead of the september 11 20th
anniversary this weekend we've spoken to
the first fire chief on the scene of the
world trade center attacks joseph
pfeiffer he's revealed how things
unfolded that day
somebody yelled the building is
collapsing
and we started to run
however with helmet and bunker coat
pants and boots
you don't run
too far or too fast
in 11 seconds
and then this beautiful
summer morning
full of sunshine
goes completely black
where we couldn't see a thing
and then all that noise from the
crashing steel and concrete
goes silent
it was like a new snowfall
this muffled
sound of silence
and for a few seconds
we wondered if we were still alive
and you can watch my full interview with
joseph five for today at half past seven
on the program uh heading to new york uh
tomorrow to bring you extensive coverage
here on sky news 20th anniversary of 9
11 this saturday health secretary sanji
javid is with us do you remember where
you were when it happened yes i do i'll
never forget i was working on the
trading floor in the city
and uh
one thing i won't forget is that we had
a live sort of phone connection at all
times with our trading floor in the
world trade center and we could hear the
sounds and the the noises coming live
down the line and yeah i'd never forget
that no one could did all your
colleagues get out yes they did thank
well
almost all of them sadly some did not
20th anniversary can't believe it really
can we um i want to talk to you about um
health and social care in just a second
but given that we're talking about that
can i ask you about afghanistan the
taliban's appointed a caretaker
government one of the the interior
minister is on the fbi's most wanted are
they people that we can do business with
well i would say in the last 24 hours i
haven't had much time to look at the
afghanistan caretaker government
but i think that as a general
point that now the afghanistan clearly
seem to be in charge
that we need to keep under review how we
work with them but is also going to be
in our long-term interest to make sure
that we can continue to help people in
afghanistan especially those people that
we have commitments to that are still
trying to leave we can work with the
terrorist government though can we no
i'm not saying we should recognize the
government prime minister's been very
clear about this that if we eventually
formally recognize a government then
there's certain things that we will be
looking for not just in behavior but how
they also deal with
other governments as well and and some
of the plans that they make but what we
should always be doing is looking to
find ways to help those people that
still need our support in afghanistan
something that you're very comfortable
talking about of course this morning is
health and social care
um i read in the papers it's the highest
taxes since the second world war
um you sure you're in the right party
yes i'm sure of that i think what we've
announced in the last 24 hours actually
is a very conservative thing to do we
are committed as a party to the nhs i
want the nhs to be there for everyone a
world-class health service free at the
point of views paid through general
taxation i as a health secretary when i
came into this job a couple of months
ago and i was told that the waiting list
already at 5.5 million because of the
global pandemic and the pressures that's
created could go to as high as 13
million in three years time i can't
tolerate that i can't accept that so
something had to be done and i think the
british public understand that similarly
with adult social care i think the fact
that some people who have this risk of
catastrophic cares uh cost your care of
cost
that that is not acceptable where you
have some one in seven people that have
to pay over a hundred thousand pounds
for their care i think it's a very
conservative thing to do to give people
that confidence that to know that their
lifetime cost of care can be capped for
them the plan is to cap that at 86 000
pounds i think is the right thing to do
and to do it properly and sustainably i
don't like raising taxes i want taxes to
be as low as they possibly can be but i
think people understand if we want the
nhs to be there for us always doing its
job then uh we've got to properly fund
that and the same applies to adult
social care this is going to be enough
money or will we be potentially looking
at more tax rises no i think this is
enough money i mean this is a it's a
very large amount of money it's around
12 billion pounds a year so over the
three year uh next three years 36
billion pounds uh it's around 16 billion
of that directly to the nhs that will
pay for things like 9 million more
checks scans and treatments helping to
tackle that waiting list it's also over
5 billion pounds more for the adult
social care system not just paying for
that that cap but also a more generous
means-tested system more support for the
workforce these are exactly the kind of
changes we need to make but only one in
only a pound in every six is going to go
to social care and that in a couple of
years time almost all of it is going to
go to the nhs um can you guarantee that
the money will go to social care in the
in the fullness of time
yes the money that we've planned because
damian green who you know is a former
cabinet office minister saying
the 5.4 billion will go to social care
that's uh that that's that's clearly set
out in our plans and in fact we're
already working yeah that's yes it will
go because you've made lots of promises
in your manifesto and you've broken
those well i'm very happy to talk about
that and the prime minister has been
very clear on that when questioned
yesterday so he was asked for example
around the promise not to raise
national insurance and other tax rates
and you know what we could have done the
options were we could have just doggedly
stuck to that and said you know
we know there's been a global pandemic
we know that the nhs and social care
facing their biggest challenges in their
lifetime but you know what we've got a
promise on the on the on taxes and we're
not going to touch them and therefore
people will just have to live with this
risk and and that's not that's not the
what a responsible government would do
the job of a responsible government
yeah my viewers this morning will say
yeah but you've broken two election
promises within two years and i think
your viewers will also see
through their own regions the areas that
they live the pressures that are on the
nhs they can see the rise in the waiting
list has already taken place to 5.5
million and just imagine if it was going
to go to 13 million if it had been
business as usual that's what was that's
what's likely to have happened a 13
million waiting list that could have
been one person in every family on the
waiting list i'm the health secretary
health and social care sector i can't
have that and i don't think your viewers
want that and so it has to be paid for
when you're going to pay for that you
can't then just say we're going to
borrow it as some people suggested
yesterday why don't you just borrow it
because that's just really putting off
the problem and moving it to the next
generation it's just a future tax rise
for our young people today we've got to
confront it and that means everyone
paying into it together i think the way
the chancellor has come up with the
money which is mainly through this
increase in national insurance their
health and social care levy and ring
fenced it and guaranteed that it will
always in the future go to health and
social care i think that's the right way
to do it and it's a very progressive way
to do it are you saying that the nhs
wasn't in trouble before covert
the nhs of course it's always you know
it's it's the
biggest no it's the biggest universal
health service in the world it's always
had challenges for as long as i can
remember but i think the difference now
is that with the global pandemic and
what that's unleashed it's the biggest
challenge in its in living memory i
think it's fair to say that and i'm full
of nothing but praise for everyone that
works in the nhs and how they have
handled uh this pandemic and they also
deserve this support making sure that
they've got the equipment that they need
the ppe they need the new technology
that they need and that we continue to
invest so for example one of the things
i'll be doing with this money is
creating a lot more of what i call
surgical hubs because if i look at that
waiting list a lot of the waiting is for
treatments like it might be like a hip
replacement a cataract surgery and if we
can create more of these dedicated hubs
we can offer more of these treatments
you know come rain or shine every day
they're available while the nhs gets on
with other work as well so are you
saying are you saying that this money
will guarantee to clear the backlog
no no responsible health secretary can
make that kind of guarantee
enough money
by saying it was enough money because we
know because we've worked with the nhs
uh very closely as you would imagine and
we have thought carefully about the
money that's needed but we've also had
to make some assumptions and
on things that no one can tell you
what's actually going to happen so with
covid the pathway of cobit no one in the
world knows what happens next with covid
so i have to make assumptions about for
example how much testing we need to do
how much we will spend on vaccines and
on ppe we've also had to make
assumptions about the the the amount of
um the capacity in the nhs and how how
we can increase that so what we've
worked out with the nhs for example is
that the nhs will be able to operate at
110
of
its normal capacity a year so it can get
through a lot more
treatments and checks and scans than
before so i'm going to be working
hand-in-hand really closely with the new
chief executive of the nhs and making
sure that together we're doing
everything we can what i can be
absolutely certain of is that this will
massively reduce the waiting list from
where it would otherwise have been it
will hugely tackle it and that's what i
think your viewers would expect me to do
vaccinations let's talk about that given
that we're talking about uh kovid where
are we with the booster jabs because
depends who you're talking to as to
whether or not they're a good idea
we've received interim advice on
boosters and that was a few weeks ago
when i published it and that was clear
that there should be some kind of
booster program so i'm i'm very
confident there will be a booster
program but in terms well
in terms of who actually gets it and
when we're waiting for final advice
which could come across in certainly in
the next few days from the jcvi and i
need to see that advice because they
rightly are looking at studies that
they've done
to look at what should be
it should be mixing vaccines for example
should people get the same vaccine
they're also looking at whether it makes
sense to co-administer it for everyone
with a flu jab as well so that work is
almost done and based on the the
timeline that they've given us i am
confident that we can start the booster
program this month you don't always take
the advice of the jcvi though do you um
i have done yes and including
yes i thought you were going to say that
and i've taken their advice because what
was their advice their advice was that
they've looked at this
and they are only by statute able to
look at the the health side of
vaccination they're not able to look at
wider issues when it comes to children
such as
impact on their education schooling and
things like that and they've said that
they recommended to me their advice was
that you should ask these the chief
medical officers of the uk collectively
for their opinion because they don't
feel qualified to talk about issues that
are not in their mandate i've taken
their advice okay so are 12 to 15 year
olds going to have jobs i don't know i
haven't got the advice from the
chief medical officers um i i would
expect i i i couldn't put a timeline on
them i think that would be unfair
because they've got to come to their own
judgment
independently they've had kids have gone
back to school well the chief medical
officers have had about four days so
of course as we both know have had
significantly longer than that you would
have thought that you'd be able to
dovetail that back into kids going back
to school well the chief medical
officers is who i'm waiting for uh now
and
i want to give them the breathing space
it's their independent view and and
that's exactly what it should be but i i
i i would expect to hit from them the
next few days how would you feel about
12 to 15 year olds of yours having jabs
i don't think it's appropriate for me to
pass a judgment because i'm waiting for
an independent view do you think that 12
to 15 year olds should be able to
overrule their parents on whether or not
they should have jobs i think we should
follow the same rules that we've had in
this country under successive
governments for for decades which is
that uh you first would try to seek the
consent of parents or parents we're
going to ask all parents for consent and
uh in most cases
if they don't give uh consent and
children still want their exactly so if
there's a difference of opinion between
the child
and the parent
then we have a specialist that let's say
that work in this area this school's
vaccination service they would usually
literally sit down with the parent and
the child and try to reach some kind of
consensus if ultimately that doesn't
work
as long as we believe that the child is
competent enough to make this decision
then the child's will will prevail how
do you feel about an october fire break
if necessary would you support it
um what do you mean by that i mean by uh
by that potentially
fire break lock down whatever you want
to call it in order to in in some form
or another in order to try to stop the
virus um getting legs again going into
the winter well i don't think that uh
that's something we need to consider i
didn't think that last year look look it
is true that no one knows the future
pathway of this uh
of this i'm guessing you'd support it so
i'm not i haven't even thought about
that as a as an option at this point
because i think the decisions well no as
the decisions that we've made in the
last uh few weeks and certainly in the
time i've been health secretary i think
they've turned out to be the right
decisions uh we've shown that we're
being chill to eat out to help out this
time last year
well
i i wasn't in government this time last
year so you can get a minister in that
that you was making whatever decision
i can talk about the decisions that have
been made since i've been in government
and especially especially around it
means that it won't we won't have
another way if you're going to support a
fire break aren't you obviously well
i've told you i think that what we are
the policies that we followed uh so far
they're based on the the best
information the best evidence that we
can get we listen to our experts
of course as anyone would expect and so
when we made the recent decision to
start opening up the country to move the
social distancing restrictions for
example and other rules that i think
that's turned out to be exactly the
right decision and it's not risk-free
when you make these decisions none of
them are risk-free no one knows exactly
what's going on nobody wants to be in
your issues that's obviously the ca i
mean you're doing an incredible job
given the challenges that you're facing
but nevertheless very much well it's
true it's
true you exactly bought you better
bottle it because i don't think i'm not
sure how often it's going to come along
but
people at home will want to know whether
if when it's october half term
potentially it that could be two weeks
for kids as a result of uh trying to
stop um another wave third fourth fifth
wave whatever we're counting uh our best
defense against another wave or
mukobidev taking off again is the
vaccine wall of defense that's been
hugely successful we've got eighty
percent of adults now that are double
vaccinated and uh we
you would continue to build in that
program we've just talked about boosters
uh for example as well
last week i also announced
a third
dose for those that are immunosuppressed
because again we're always looking at
the evidence to see what more we can do
the vaccines are working yes there are
still infections of course there's still
all that's true around the world but the
number of people going into hospital and
certainly those dying is mercifully low
and that's because of the vaccines
we're out of time but we're just about
to head to um calais to our reporter on
the boat uh 54 million pounds is how
much we want to give to the french are
we getting value for money from them
when it comes to well
i think i i think it's look it's uh when
i was home secretary i was working with
the french on the on the same issue and
uh they you know they in my experience
is that it's really good to cooperate
look this is a joint problem between the
french and the british and uh
and i think it makes absolute sense to
to work together to share intelligence
and see what you can do okay it's good
to talk to you i have to let you go it's
great to see you thank you thank you
very much
just a second um adam is joining us live
from a boat in cala hello to you adam a
very good morning you heard what the
former home secretary now health
secretary had to say working closely
with the french is it working
it's sort of working but it's a massive
mountain and today pretty patella is
going to be meeting uh her counterparts
from france dominion and saying
that she's going to threaten to withhold
54 million pounds
of funding that the uk
is about to give to the french to
support the programme to try and
intercept migrants in these waters these
uh that's
blejo around their song just around the
corner these are names synonymous with
hundreds thousands of migrants who over
the years have tried to get from these
waters uh over to the united kingdom and
in the
four or five hours we've now spent it in
the waters i think we've got a sense of
why this is so difficult when we were
here uh when it was absolutely pitch
black
you could just see it's almost
impossible frankly okay to tell the
difference between uh the shapes that
you see is that a wave is it rubbish on
the water is it a bird could it be
a boat very hard to see that we only see
one patrol vessel going past
uh during that night so if you timed
your boat leaving well then you could
avoid detection i have seen another
patrol vessel uh over there in the past
sort of 10 or or 15 minutes or so so
you're not seeing waves after waves of
them but this is a
coastline that goes on for tens of miles
to patrol it constantly would be
completely impossible and the local mp
here says that 54 million pounds just
isn't enough effectively to even scratch
the surface of preventing people from
making this journey the thing that has
the biggest impact probably is the
weather on a day like today blue skies
calm weather people are bound to try to
make this journey pretty patel wants the
french to do more the french reaction
frankly is that they are doing just
about as much as they can
okay thank you adam thanks a lot
in other news people living in parts of
northern england were more likely to die
from covid spent more time in lockdown
and took a larger financial hit during
the first year
joining me now is our correspondent
sadia chadry who is standing by in
manchester for us um basically
underlining what we heard from the mayor
of greater manchester andy burnham
during the during the cove pandemic
yes this is a real snapshot of how the
pandemic impacted people in the north
and the researchers are saying it was
uneven and disproportionate so it's
things like more deaths i think only
north yorkshire and cumbria had a lower
covered mortality rate than the
national average national average there
was more mental health issues there were
26 percent more deaths in care homes for
example 19 greater rate of unemployment
than the rest of the country and also
when it came to addressing the pandemic
people in the north spent longer in
lockdown as you say okay so uh 41 days
more
in lockdown than the rest of the country
you remember that liverpool was the
first country to go into the top tier
when the tier systems came around in
manchester here where i am one of the
last to come out of it but it wasn't all
bad news some of it was positive when it
came to the vaccine rollout in the first
six months of the rollout the
vaccination rate in the north of the
country was greater than the rest of the
country um but the researchers are
saying that the reason why the impact
has been so bad uh for people here was
because of uh greater deprivation and
poorer pre-pandemic health and they're
calling this a wake-up call and saying
there needs to be greater investment in
the north okay thank you thanks a lot
looking at the latest covered figures
for you they're looking something like
this 37
489 new cases were reported a further
209 people have sadly died the first
time the number has been
above 200 since the 1st of march it
takes the total number who've died
within 28 days of a positive test to 133
4483
22 700 first doses given yesterday 80
000 people received their second host 43
and a half million people now fully
vaccinated
so to come on the program before you
quarter to eight i'm going to be
speaking to the surgeon who separated
conjoined twins
[Music]
20 past day former uk ambassador to
afghanistan so nick k will be with me to
discuss the taliban's interim cabinet
and the wider implications of their
takeover
quarter to nine we'll speak to the
former welsh rugby player gareth thomas
about why many men are still reluctant
to discuss their health concerns
time though for a look at this morning's
other main stories here on sky the trial
of the 2015 paris attacks begin today
with 20 people expected to appear before
the court included including i should
say salah abdullah the only living
suspect islamic extremists killed 130
people when they detonated multiple
bombs and shot concert goers and those
enjoying a meal out in the french
capital today will mark france's biggest
ever trial
u.s president joe biden has declared
climate change everybody's crisis as he
visited neighborhoods severely damaged
by the remnants of hurricane ida and
said it's time for america to get
serious about the dangers or face even
worse disaster
climate change poses an existential
threat to our lives
to our economy and the threat is here
it's not going to get any better
the question can't it get
worse
we can stop it from getting worse
and so folks we got to listen to the
scientists and the economist and the
national security experts they all tell
us this is code red
the nation and the world are in peril
that's not hyperbole
that is a fact
these 17 patients have been killed after
heavy rainfall caused flooding at a
hospital in mexico's central hidalgo
state
patients at the public hospital in the
northern mexico town of tula were
evacuated from the area after torrential
rains flooded the hospital the hospital
had been caring for 56 patients about
half of them suffering from covid 19.
looking at the impact of climate change
on the planet this is our dashboard for
you 26
of our power at the moment is coming
from nuclear second line that's how much
hotter it is now than when records first
began in 1880 1.23 degrees
time left
uh 11 years
four months if that temperature gets to
one and a half degrees that's the point
of no return according to scientists and
the scary figure at the bottom that is
the co2 emissions in millions of tons
and you can keep up with all the stories
affected by the global climate on the
daily climate show right here live on
sky news every weekday live 6 30.
so what's the weather going to look like
today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the answer is it's looking like a heat
wave three days running above 28 degrees
it's continuing for many today changes
are underway though with the weather set
to turn cooler and more unsettled over
the next few days
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
love these pictures seen them in the
papers today i wanted to share them with
you and air force sergeant supporting
the kabul evacuations shared a picture
of the moment he took hold of a two-week
old baby over here who was dropped by
her ex exhausted mom during an airlift
out of afghanistan obviously a daddy put
these on to protect the baby's ears mom
um was absolutely exhausted so what
happened sergeant andy livingston took
care of the little one while mum had
some sleep these pictures uh posted
online as i said in most of the papers
today
how amazing is that
after the break
it was like a new snowfall
this muffled
sound of silence
and for a few seconds
we wondered if we were still alive
remembering 9 11 we speak to the first
fire chief on the scene at the world
trade center attacks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone this week marks the 20th
anniversary actually of the 9 11 attacks
to mark the occasion we've spoken to the
very first new york fire chief to arrive
at the scene of the world trade center
attacks chief
joseph pfeiffer told me the harrowing
story of how that momentous day unfolded
as you'll hear it began with his fire
battalion investigating a simple gas
leak report be prepared this is a
harrowing encounter
we were at a odor of gas to the street a
routine emergency
nothing to get too excited about since
we weren't getting any uh
any indications that we did have a gas
leak
and then all of a sudden we heard a loud
noise of a plane coming overhead
and you never hear planes in manhattan
because of the tall buildings
and then i saw this plane
flying at a very low altitude
and an extremely fast speed
that zoomed past us
and then i saw the plane aim
and
crash into the north tower of the world
trade center every first responder
firefighters police officers emts and
paramedics
every one of them
saw the burning towers
and even though this this is our job
they made a personal decision to go into
danger
because we all knew
we were going to the most dangerous fire
of our lives
17 minutes after the first plane hit we
heard another loud
noise of of racing jet engines almost
like a fighter jet it sounded like
um and this was the second plane
that crashed into the south tower
so now we have
two 110 story buildings
on fire
and thousands of people
in the greatest moment of need the
planes were deliberately chosen to be
hijacked because they were due to fly to
various airports in california as a
result they had an awful lot of jet fuel
on them that's why the buildings burned
so ferociously for such a long time
when the fire officers were coming down
i think you were engine 33 many many
other fire officers from all around the
area coming down to try to help when you
were sending them into those buildings
did you have any concept
of what was going to happen
the plan was
to use
since we had no elevators working
to send the firefighters up
and i told them
to
do two things one
to evacuate the building
and then two will regroup on the upper
floors
to rescue those that couldn't get out
was that a scene of calmness or chaos
can you can you take us back and tell us
what it was like
the lobby where we set up our command
post
for the north tower
there was spoken glass everywhere
there was cracked marble
falling off the wall
and the firefighters came in quietly
they didn't say a lot and that's unusual
for firefighters they
like to talk um
but they came in quietly except for the
banging of some of the tools
um
they had a
grim look on their face
because they knew they were going to the
most hazardous fire
of their lives
and
that morning
not only did we
were concerned about the fires
but as the fires spread
we heard another noise
and that was
people jumping
and they landed on
a canopy over the front of the
the the entrance to the lobby
with a loud thud
and we knew that each thud
was the end of a life
and then at one moment i got so
frustrated that i got on the pa system
and i told them i told people if at all
possible hang on we're coming up for you
but i only could imagine
what a decision that they had to make
between burning
or jumping
your brother kevin also a firefighter
he came to join you didn't he um at the
north tower
can you tell us what happened next
a little bit before nine o'clock
my brother
kevin
uh from engine 33 he was a lieutenant in
engine 33.
he reported into me
and i can remember
we looked at each other
and we had a concerned look on
on on his face
and we worried
whether each of us was going to be okay
and he didn't say a word
we just had a moment
of
understanding that this was going to be
a tough day did you at any stage there
chief think
i don't want him to go into this tower i
want him to stay here with me
i treated him
as i did
my other
brother and sister firefighters
um i worried about them
i worried about
about the other firefighters
and i gave my brother
as well the uh the other fire officers
that
came in
to go up
go up evacuate and then rescue those
that were trapped
all the while people were flooding down
the stairwells trying to get out the
elevators weren't working the jet fuel
had come down the elevator shafts it was
setting fire to floors left right and
center
did it become more and more chaotic in
the lobbies what was happening then and
what were the comms like
people came down
and they were very orderly
as firefighters were going up
the narrow stairs people were coming
down
and the firefighters did some
ordinary things
they said
to the people coming down don't stop
you can make it out of here keep going
and we know from
people who survived
those simple words
made the difference
and and perhaps
[Music]
that's the reason
that i chose for my memoirs
the title of ordinary heroes
because at this extraordinary time in
history
our firefighters
did ordinary things
to make a difference between life and
death
when they started to collapse when the
south tower collapsed first although
that was the second one to be hit and
then the north tower collapsed about
half an hour after that where were you
and and what did you do
at 9 59
we heard a loud rumbling sound
and if you were watching it on a
newscast
you saw that that was
the south tower collapsing
i had no idea that that a whole building
was falling to the ground i thought part
of the elevator debris was coming down
the elevator shaft or part of the plane
fell off and was crashing through the
windows in the lobby
but the lobby goes completely black
where
we couldn't see anything
and at that point we knew we couldn't
command any longer
and i got on my radio
and i said
command to all units in tower one
evacuate the building
and they started to come down
our firefighters
then what happened
then
29 minutes later
i made it out to the street
standing in front of the north tower
and we hear a rumbling sound again
and this time somebody yelled the
building is collapsing
and we started to run
however with helmet and bunker coat
pants and and boots
you don't run
too far or too fast
in 11 seconds
and then this beautiful summer morning
full of sunshine
goes completely black
where we couldn't see a thing
and then all that noise from the
crashing steel and concrete
goes silent
it was like a new snowfall
this muffled
sound of silence
and for a few seconds
we wondered if we were still alive
and what would you like um the people
of the united kingdom and indeed around
the world what would you like them to be
thinking
i would like people to remember
not just the collapse and the tragedy
but also
this sense of unity that we felt
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
that we were in this together
um
and i like them to take
that that that feeling
of of of unity
and see if we could apply it to today's
fragmented world
and then
i like especially the young people
as they look at it maybe for the first
time
that they think of
they think of heroes
not as super superheroes of
but rather of ordinary heroes
of a person
they can become someday
to make a difference
in other people's lives
my goodness may i tell you it was a
tough watch tonight he was the first
fire chief on the scene uh
2001
september the 11th 20 years ago since al
qaeda terrorists hijacked four
commercial jets packed with passengers
and flew them
into three targeted buildings in new
york and in washington one of them
landing in shanksville pennsylvania
after those on board managed to wrestle
the controls of the airplane from the
terrorists that thought that that plane
was either heading to the white house or
to the capitol building
yesterday the former u.s national
security adviser john bolton recounted
his memories of what happened that day
i went to my office which was on the
southwest corner of the seventh floor of
the state department and somebody ran in
and said the pentagon's been hit so i
went to the window i could see the smoke
and the flames from the pentagon
full coverage of the 9 11 attack 20
years on from 5 p.m on friday going to
be in new york that evening and on
saturday the day of the anniversary full
coverage from nine o'clock in the
morning right through for the whole of
the commemorations to 10 30 p.m on
saturday evening
actually i was chatting to the health
secretary a short time ago he was
telling me that he was a trader in the
city at the time of 9 11 and not all of
his colleagues made it out of the twin
towers they had an open line to their
colleagues in the twin towers not all of
them he said made it out you can hear
what he had to say about that online if
you would like to or my twitter account
at caberle also asked him about the
highest taxes since the second world war
in order to pay for health and social
care his views on that in just a second
but also asked him about boosters kids
have just gone back to school should
adults be looking to having boosters um
talked about that and in addition to
that asked him about jabs for 12 to 15
year olds and if parents said they
didn't want their kids to have those
jabs could children of 12 as young as 12
still go ahead and have one
i think we should follow the same rules
that we've had in this country and the
successive governments for for decades
which is that
you first would try to seek the consent
of parents or parents we're going to ask
all parents for consent and uh in most
cases but what if they don't give it as
much if they don't give consent and
children still want their exactly so if
there's a difference of opinion between
the child
and the parent
then we have a specialist that let's say
that work in this area this school's
vaccination service they would usually
literally sit down with the parent and
the child and try to reach some kind of
consensus if ultimately that doesn't
work as long as we believe that the
child is competent enough to make this
decision then the child's will will
prevail
tomorrow on downing street for us this
morning hello to you tomorrow i found
that staggering that he was suggesting
to us that 12 year old the man who's in
charge of the health of the nation says
12 year olds can overrule their parents
that was interesting and also the length
of waiting lists that we might have here
in the uk
that was interesting on 12 to 15 year
olds because there's been some real
mixed messages on this coming out of
government to tell you where we are on
jabs for 12 to 15 year olds they're
happening in a number of other european
countries and in the us they are not
happening here as yet except for 12 to
15 year olds with an underlying serious
health condition who having it already
the government was advised by its
advisors on vaccines that there was only
a marginal benefit for giving it for 12
to 15 year olds because they're not at
risk of seriously getting covered but we
are expecting a ruling from the chief
medical officers possibly as soon as
this week because they don't judge it
just on that narrow basis of whether
they will get serious covid but on loss
of education risk to the rest of society
so they will make a recommendation this
week and if they recommend going ahead
with it that could start in schools very
very soon parents will be asked for
consent but this is i think the first
explicit confirmation from the health
secretary that if this is not expected
to be widespread but in the rare
instances where a child and a parent
differ and the child is competent to
make that decision they will prevail so
that will be news to a lot of parents
this morning certainly will tomorrow for
now thanks so much indeed tomorrow live
in dining street for us today i'm
talking about parents and their children
britney spears dad has filed a petition
to end the 13-year legal conservatorship
that gave him control over his
daughter's life career and also finances
so what does that mean joining us from
washington to discuss this is our u.s
political commentator and journalist
scotty nel hughes hi scotty thanks for
joining us so is he throwing in the
towel or is he saying to a judge you
decide
oh no he's definitely throwing in the
top but realize this k the only reason
why he's doing it is because he realized
that the legal walls were starting to
close in i think jamie spears brittany's
father realized years ago he didn't care
about the pr battle he cared about
continuing to have control over his
daughter's life but over the last few
months the legal battles which normally
had been going in his favor have been
turned to turn the tide and gone into
brittany's favor saying that she could
actually now go in july and pick her own
attorney and ever since she got this new
very aggressive
attorney named matthew rosengard who
made it a point to see her wish that her
father potentially could be sent to jail
because of abuses that brittany felt
like she had during her time as him
being her conservator
he has been very aggressive and said
just because he's relinquishing does not
mean that we're not going to continue to
pursue legal justice for brittany
considering everything that she's gone
through the past 13 years at the hands
of her father
when will we know
well you're going to know what about
well it's going to happen it's going to
be the end of september is the actual
court date and you have to remember
britney spears estate right now is only
worth and i say only about 60 million
which is incredibly low considering she
is a woman who's produced basically a
hit with every album since she first
started on the stage in 1998 with baby
hit me one more time so there was a lot
of question of where all the money has
gone then you bring in the charges of
abuse including sexual abuse as well as
possible uh extortion in various forms
and there's a lot of questions right now
that does not put jamie lynn spears in
actually good favor with any judge who
looked at this case and finally having
honest and truth uh being spoken about
is not only welcomed by brittany's fans
but also about the other 1.3 million
adults in america who are conservative
under conservative ships themselves 50
billion dollars worth of assets this is
exposed a lot bigger of a problem pay in
america considering what this entire
program has been and put a lot shed a
light on something that's been kind of
swept under the rug for decades
just before i let you go only a short
amount of time left scotty
what do we know about her mental health
at the moment i have seen some um
concerning pictures on social media
well obviously there's a lot of concern
concerning pictures but it was also said
that her father uh drugged her all of
these years so who knows what the
effects of those drugs might be i think
we're not going to know the truth about
her until after this conservatorship is
done and her attorney's able to get some
unbiased medical help for brittany to
assess where her mental health is after
like i said 13 years of abuse can take a
toll and i think it's going to take
obviously some real people with unbiased
opinions get in there and actually
assess her uh without having to worry
about possible ramifications from her
father anymore
scottie good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time
thank
you now the odds of it happening are
more than one in a million and when it
does happen the chances of survival are
low
what are we talking about
conjoined twins that are born
at the head the outlook very bleak but a
new charity called gemini entwined which
specializes in surgical separation is
giving parents of conjoined twins the
chance to return home with two healthy
children
let's speak now should we to the founder
of that charity the pediatric
neurosurgeon owaisi gilani hello t
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning you've just separated uh
two little girls i think haven't you
that were joined at the head tell us
what happened
uh yes we did the surgery last week in
israel uh the surgery went well we're
delighted to say the girls are doing
really well at this early stage how
complicated was it
um i mean all conjoined twin procedures
are complicated but on a spectrum of the
ones we've done one of the lesser
complicated ones
what are the risks involved
um
with with all these surgeries there's
always the risk of losing one or both
children at the time of the surgery
so that risk was there with this set as
well and the other risks of causing
injury to the brain the blood vessels
causing a stroke
um it's it's a high stakes uh high
stakes undertaking
um
one thinks that it's very unusual to see
this sort of situation but you know you
have set up a charity so perhaps more
common than people might think
um well we we believe that there's
probably about a dozen or such uh or so
kids born globally every year and whilst
we're really fortunate here in the uk
we've managed to gather the world's
largest experience with our team of five
cases now most centers most countries in
the world would not have dealt with such
a such a scenario so the whole idea is
you know whilst it's well and good that
we can do these surgeries
it doesn't really benefit um the
children let's say born in africa or
other parts of the world at this stage
so the whole concept of the charity was
how do we collate all the learning that
we have got in this country and our team
and how do we disseminate and uh thereby
help the kids um and the families in
other parts of the world that was the
focus of the charity
we said
tell me a little bit about how people
find out more about the charity if you
would please doctor
uh so it's gemini entwined
we have a website and uh please do visit
the website it tells you about the work
we do and how we are at the moment
trying to help other families that are
in this position so we're actively
helping other families in the situation
as we speak
and doctor what about going back to
these two little girls they have now
been separated i'm guessing it was a
massive team to to deal with that
operation and then the aftercare how are
they doing now
uh the girls are doing well the girls
are doing well we're six days after the
surgery we're delighted to see they're
doing so well at this stage it's still
early days though you know one does need
to wait a few weeks at least to make
sure there are no infections or any
other complications but you know there's
every reason to be optimistic
at the moment
and they can go on to have a normal life
indeed indeed that's our expectation our
hope
that's absolutely fantastic uh
congratulations doctor and hopefully
people will go along to the website and
check out how they can support other
youngsters around the world with a
similar condition thank you for joining
us on the programme
bye-bye
bye-bye thank you
have a look at these images we've got
some crackers for you today anyone
with a fear of heights or falling should
look away right now including me alain
robert known as the french spider-man
has been climbing another tower on the
outskirts of paris while usually doing
solo climbs this time it was accompanied
by three other young climbers he's 60
he was arrested more than an hour into
his equipment-free climb for endangering
lives of others and placed into police
custody so climbing up the side of that
building
and had absolutely no equipment to keep
him on the side of the building
be mad uh we'll have more on that in the
next hour here on sky news more also on
uh what sati javid the health secretary
has said to me this morning he's been
talking primarily about uh the fact that
taxes national insurance tax will go up
by one and a quarter percent he was
justifying that despite being a
conservative uh cabinet minister he was
saying that it was the conservative
thing to do that was very fascinating
chat and he hopes that the money will be
used to reduce the waiting list but he
also
very interestingly talked about jabs for
12 to 15 year olds you know it's an
incredibly hot topic at the moment and
he is the most senior health minister
that i've certainly heard from i don't
know what you think and he was saying 12
year olds can have depending on what the
chief medical officer says but in his
opinion 12 year olds should be able
to speak to their parents and then if
their parents say we don't want you to
have this vaccine and the 12 year old
does then the 12 year old can overrule
their parents and have a vaccine for
covid 19. so i suppose if you take that
to the logical conclusion these 12 year
olds could have parents that are
anti-vaxxers for example they're saying
under no circumstances are you having
that and the 12 year old goes back to
school and says you know i still want to
have it what do you think about that
that's a fascinating talking point isn't
it here on sky news this morning you can
tweet me directly if you would like to
at k burley talking about that and also
the first firefighter on the scene of
911 in just a moment
[Music]